yeah I get helpings mediately if you
have a relative who's lost interest in
everything it doesn't get out of bed or
doesn't care for things they used to
can't imagine anything that would give
them any pleasure don't fool around with
it get therapy get help get medication
if that's right for you or talk therapy
or something but the very simple reason
that you don't want to fool with it is
people with depression commit suicide
there's a lot more to know about
depression than that glib answer but and
it's night I'm not glad I've had
depression but the payoff if there is
any has been the fact that I talked
about it and the people have said on the
street even you saved my dad's life he
thought if this could happen to you it's
alright for it to happen to him there
one of the uses of celebrity perhaps or
money saved my daughter who always liked
you and then she said gee he's got had
this and I whatever but but it's it's
ticking time-bomb it ends and it does
not help to tell the person suffering it
get up and get out and have some fun and
forget it stop thinking about yourself
and pull up your socks and play some
tennis and you'll be fine that is that
it'll help to play tennis because you'll
have some endorphins moving and you'll
feel a little better but you don't do
any favors to the depressed person by
saying come on snap out of it
I didn't get help quick very no I should
have gotten help a lot earlier I did I
suppose the first and second times
because you think this can't be
happening again but but but the help is
there and it must be used